Canada's prime minister just accused
India of assassinating somebody on
Canadian soil potential link between
agents of the government of India and
the killing of a Canadian citizen let me
explain why this is a big deal pardeep
Singh nijar moved to Canada from India
and was a leader of the kalistan
movement an effort to create an
independent state for Sikhs a religious
minority in Northern India the Indian
government called this guy a terrorist
and has been trained to arrest him for
years nijar found refuge in Canada where
nearly a million Sikhs live that is
until recently when he was gunned down
by two men outside of a temple in
Vancouver India denied any involvement
in this but Justin Trudeau's accusation
that India was involved means that
there's at least some credible evidence
here but we just don't know yet the
whole thing is causing some real tension
between the two countries and it's right
at a time when the West is trying to
strengthen its relationship with India
as a part of its efforts to
counterbalance China so I guess now we
just wait and see what evidence comes
out if you want to better understand
global politics follow for more